[Music]
to a crash now involving an off-duty
Metro officer and another driver has
turned fatal Authority
Authority freeway was last Wednesday but
he's now since died the officer who was
driving the other car initially facing
DUI charges his family speaking with
eight news now reporter Victoria Saha on
what they're now going through
family identifies the victim as 79 year
old David Earl Kingsley his grandson
tells me it was pretty touch and go this
weekend as Kingsley was fighting for his
life but the fact that this crash was
caused by an off-duty officer makes
their pain so much worse
Dominic Garcia is remembering his
grandpa David Kingsley who was more like
a dad to him I told him that I'd be with
him from uh
beginning to then and Garcia was there
till the end as his family made the
gut-wrenching decision to take his
grandpa off breathing machines after
being involved in a horrific crash he
got damaged to his spine his eyes
and he was paralyzed he also broke his
neck Garcia says Kingsley was on his way
to the dog park with his dog Nikita just
before five in the morning around the
same time a car driven by off-duty Metro
officer Benjamin corias was overturned
on the highway after hitting another car
this is when Garcia's grandfather ran
into him what were your thoughts when
you found out it was an off-duty Metro
officer
it just gave me nothing but anger Nevada
State Police say 24 year old koreas
showed signs of impairment and was
arrested your job is to arrest people
who do that so it makes you think it's
okay for you too
it's not right
officer careers has been with Metro
since 2020 he'll be back in court in
June for his arraignment so now that the
alleged victim has died that certainly
changes what's going to be happening to
this Metro officer moving forward right
yeah Denise originally the officer was
facing reckless driving charges and
failure to decrease speed and all those
are considered misdemeanors but we did
reach out to the city of Las Vegas they
said those charges could change as well
and what about the dog he was going to
the dog park any idea did the dog
survive the crash yeah so much going on
there the grandson tells me Animal
Control took the dog to the animal
foundation the dog has since given birth
to seven puppies disease yeah and the
family is trying to get the dogs back
because they say their grandfather
adored that dog named Nikita she's just
a few years old but the city of Las
Vegas says they're being held right now
because the family isn't licensed to
breathe and the Animals aren't fixed and
it's too early to separate the pups from
the mom right now she was in spayed they
had puppies so they're holding on to her
just for now all right let us know what
happens thanks Victoria